lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en diferentes formas de
representar la multiplicación
especialmente conectado a las nociones
de con temas altos y la recta numérica
entonces si tuviéramos que pensar en lo
que significa 4 por 2 ya lo hemos visto
en otros vídeos podrías ver esto como
cuatro grupos de dos de modo que
podríamos tener cuatro grupos un grupo
dos grupos tres grupos y cuatro grupos y
cada uno de ellos tiene dos cosas puse
dos pequeños círculos aquí así que
tienes dos aquí dos aquí tienes dos aquí
y tienes dos allí y también puedes ver
eso como 4 2 o 4 2 sumados de modo que
podríamos verlo como 2 más 2 más 2 más 2
y eso por supuesto va a ser 2 más 2 4 4
2 son 6 6 más 2 son 8 tenemos que por
aquí incluso podríamos contar salteado 2
468 4 por 2 es igual a 8 también podemos
pensar en eso en una
numérica así que voy a poner aquí una
recta numérica y podríamos imaginarnos
cuatro por dos de acuerdo entonces esto
es 1 por 2 2 por 2 3 por 2 y 4 por 2
de modo que empezamos en cero e hicimos
cuatro saltos de 2 a lo largo de la
recta numérica para terminar en 8
pasamos de 0 a 2 468 simplemente
saltamos contando en 2 hasta llegar a 8
si tuviera que hacer una pregunta
similar dejen de dibujar una pequeña
serie de saltos y quiero que lo piensen
de otra manera que multiplicación
representa esto digamos que comienzo
aquí y luego voy a saltar aquí luego
aquí estoy haciendo saltos iguales cada
vez entonces voy aquí luego aquí y aquí
que representa eso si usamos el mismo
tipo de ideas bueno fui de 0 a 4 8 12 16
20 salte contando de cuatro en cuatro
así que puedes imaginar que
probablemente esto es algo multiplicado
por cuatro
ahora cuántos altos y c&c 1 2 3 4 5 así
que esto es 5 por 4 y podemos ver que
terminamos en 20 también podríamos ver
que esto es lo mismo que 5 444 más 444 y
eso se ve aquí estamos empezando en cero
estamos agregando 4 luego otros 4 luego
otros 4 otros 4 y otros 4 tenemos 54
aquí vamos a hacer uno más
de modo que voy a poner una recta
numérica por aquí y pensar de lo que
significa decir 7 por 3 bueno podríamos
ver esto como 7 saltos de 3 comenzando
en 0 7 saltos iguales
así que 1
3 4 5 6 y 7 terminamos en 21 es igual a
21 también puedes ver esto cuando
hacemos 7 grupos de tres y los sumamos y
también podrías verlo como un conteo a
saltos pasaste de 0 a 3 6 9 12 15 18 y
21 ahora solo por interés y si fuéramos
al revés y si tuviéramos que dar tres
saltos de 7 cómo sería eso pues no
comenzaríamos aquí y entonces daríamos
nuestro primer salto de 7 hasta acá
llegamos a 7 luego si damos otro salto
de 7 llegamos a 14 y luego si damos otro
salto de 7 llegamos a 21 interesante al
menos para esta situación si tomamos 7
saltos de tres o tres saltos de 7
llegamos al mismo valor exacto te invito
a pensar si ese será el caso siempre los
veo en otro vídeo